so the nfl adopted on a one-year basis
pass interference replay review calls
and non-calls of offensive and defense
pass interference it's been one of the
big controversies all year long that was
the reaction to the nfc championship
game here's the key though after the
season they've got to decide what
they're going to do chris and when it's
on a one-year basis what that means is
you need 24 votes in favor of it to keep
it right if you make it permanent you
need 24 votes against it to get rid of
it so
they've done this as a
let's see what happens type of a thing
and what's happened is it hasn't been
good and stephen jones the cowboy ceo
who's a member of the competition
committee told the fort worth star
telegram earlier this week that he's not
in favor of it he wants to see it go
away he will have an influential voice
in the process although it is hardly
dispositive i just don't know what
they're going to do and jones attitude
is you just have to accept there's going
to be bad calls you get good calls you
get bad calls stuff happens yeah let's
not try to overdo it and i know you've
you've made that similar argument in the
past the problem is
with each state that adds to the list i
got you of those that allow legalized
wagering on sports
saying
stuff happens or another word that
starts with
s then has a t in it store high transit
store high and transit that's where the
word came from right okay okay that's
fine but that's not going to be good
enough because it's one thing for the
teams to just kind of loosely agree hey
we'll tolerate whatever bad calls happen
because stuff happens and we really
don't want to spend the money to try to
improve it because we know we're not
going to improve it significantly so why
spend the money to make it better that
doesn't work on the thousands of people
tens of thousands maybe eventually
hundreds of thousands who are wagering
their money on games where there has to
be integrity to the outcome which means
you have to find a way to create the
impression you are addressing the
potential for bad calls okay so i don't
think it's going to be the nfl's
prerogative at some point congress is
going to get involved if the nfl is just
nonchalant and lackadaisical about the
idea that they have bad calls well i
mean with this year the way it's
unfolded does that make you feel more
comfortable as a gambler i mean do you
do you want to do you want to feel like
the referees in the field are in on the
fix or the guy that's in 345 park avenue
i mean but but you just can't get you
just can't say we're just going to get
rid of it and go back to what it was
before you got to have something else if
you're not going to have replay review
for past interference and i don't like
the way it's worked i don't like the
shifting standard i don't agree however
on acting like the standard didn't shift
yeah i want sky judge but here's what
look the nfl ultimately is a business
and i know that it's hard for the
average fan to understand that it's like
telling people that wrestling is fake
they don't want to hear it right they
think that everybody involved in the
sport is as passionate as they are about
winning and losing and nothing else but
ultimately for the nfl there's a balance
sheet and you've got your revenue and
you've got your expense and from the
nfl's perspective the expense that they
would incur to improve officiating to
have sky judge to have full-time
officials across the board those
millions of dollars will not be
accompanied by a spike in revenue so
profit will go down and what you have to
ask yourself and this is where it's
important to have leadership in the room
you need to protect your current
business model and if you allow these
bad calls to continue if you don't care
enough about it to make it better or
create the impression you're trying to
make it better that's when you have to
worry about the revenues dropping
dramatically or the expense is going up
even more when congress decides to
impose an external solution that's why
they should care about it chris and i
hope they figure it out before it's too
late well yeah i mean i like listen
everything you said is that's good great
i mean i'm with you the nfl's cheap you
know i mean yeah they don't want to
expect you know i was you know i was so
careful no touching and diplomatic they
are they're interested
yeah well you know me that i don't dip
my toe in i usually just jump in and
yeah i mean it's not being cheap it's b
it's spending they're spending
selectively and they're not gonna
dramatically increase expense if they
don't see a corresponding uptick in
revenue it's that simple but no business
does that okay i get it i get it but but
to your point to make the consumer feel
comfortable these are little things that
you need to do especially if you want to
continue to have legalized gambling be a
part of the sport and flourish under
that now my big thing is like yeah i you
know again what's the sky judge really
gonna fix it's still a subjective rule i
mean we sat in the room together you me
coach dungey rodney harrison all we do
is watch football and we don't always
agree on what's past interference or
what's not past interference so there's
gonna be issues here no matter what it's
not going to change much the guy the sky
judge he'll make some calls next year if
they do do that where i'm going to go
that sky judge is an idiot that's not
past interference sky judge isn't making
the call though sky judge is
collaborating
collaboration collaboration you got to
do it right it's got to cost money and
here's where the revenue comes from all
the extra money that the nfl is making
is a windfall from gambling that's where
you find the money to make officiating
better that's what the league needs to
do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports